bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
schermo blu
anzi direi proprio di no siamo subito
tali riserve che il mio inglese mi aiuta
inseguo è un gioco da fare online che
non mi ricordo per quale motivo l'ho
scelto vediamo se riesco a ricordarmelo
siamo io sono un sono uno che deve
portare le cose giustamente devo
deriverà sono un uomo delivery può fare
questo gioco sono cascato mi sono
spaccato la faccia non ho fatto niente
come si guida come si gioca aiuto anche
dobbiamo consegnare un pacco vai vai vai
velocemente lo mettono dietro io guido
mettiamo dietro guido io non so manco
salire sulla macchina figuratività kamal
vai lucius bravo luxus mettono dietro
mentito dietro
by lucio ma la mano marco demonio che
botta delivery face
l'uomo giuste di far piano va edizione
ha spiegato visto un camion capottarsi
tutto a posto tranquilli ragazzi
ragazzi ho capito come si guida e non è
per niente semplice però o meno ci
dovrei essere signor lucius dove dove
lucius maledizione credo che sia da giu
quella è la gente che è rimasta
incastrata arrivo ragazzi
[Musica]
non arrivo più guidare il gioco è un
casino alla gara non so se ve ne siete
accorti ma però sicuro io amici sono qua
all'inizio nei ragazzi sta cascare il
camion in acqua 88 o dio che si è
successo a rallenta avvisato il gioco
mamma mia a posto allora vorrei c'è
l'elicottero sto male lucius chi sei di
questi vieni con me che ti insegno
guidare l'elicottero da maraga il fatto
che ci sia l'elicottero sto malissimo
aspettare mamma mia ma è bellissimo
regalo salite salite stai appendendo ti
sta bene pubblico
oddio perché non di morirci sali qua per
favore
salì perché sembra tanto ed uscirà nella
detto al ponte comunque io non purtroppo
la tipa notevole non vuole salire
migliori contro che peccato hai perso
un'occasione
let's rock o mio dio hai fatto bene a
salire
ho mollato il tasto non volevo o regali
non va sicuro niente non vi assicuro
nulla però va bene ne andiamo a consegna
avendo un camion lo vedo arrivo arrivo
arrivo aspetto che è un casino può
aggirare
amico mio guida guida bene guida bene al
virgilio ti prego dio
vabbè non è andata così come speravo che
commettiamo flash
cambiamo mappa ragazzi ma perché tu le
consegne le prendi d'acquisto mamma o
alla mail
cosa vuoi hulk hogan schifoso pervertito
ciò permise ma basta smettila di
toccarmi nuvolosa l'elicottero le pen
elicottero
smettila l'intelligenza media di suo
gioco vedo che è questa va beh comunque
c'è l'elicottero qua
consegniamo approfittiamone maledizione
beh almeno siamo in compagnia per favore
toglietevi dalla mia vista io voglio
guidare l'elicottero occhio a maneggiare
cosa fare liquidate le dico bravi vai
vai però sollevati bravo come come
perché mi si è lasciato ragazzi aiuto
aspettatevi prego caduto programmato per
seguirvi ci provo spiega ritrovo modo
c'è un elicottero vicino un altro ma
porca vacca perché si lasciato ragazzi
state a posto no cosa sta succedendo lì
sono quasi contento io ne sarei salito
con loro occhio anche al mio dio
raggiungo la macchina in tutto questo
aspetto è bellissimo questo giorno
ragazzi e geniale se gioco genia come ho
fatto a non conoscerlo prima è
fantastico realtà ancora in versione
beta e si vede ok ora misto
ufficialmente tenendo con due mani alla
maniglia quindi puoi andare zio poi
piano per favore piano bravo ragazzo una
una kuna consegna una per favore
ancorati bene nel
ma va bene no dico io lo tengo io ho
giova incalzati molo che studiamo alzati
alzati e fai schifo pino da mamma mia ti
peggio di me non è colpa mia non è come
pensate io sto bene dai ragazzi forza
raga dai è tutto a posto tutto bene dai
amico mio boh lavora non li noli per
terra ma guarda mai avrei pensato di
dirlo ma guido meglio io ami guidare per
l'amore di gesù cristo da melo a me
faccio io faccio io non usare toccarlo
t'ammazzo non sei capace togliti a me
guida tu però per favore
liberati in volo no lo vedi che sei
stupido
mio dio che bird all iti facciano
agganciato alta di più a schiaffi te lo
giuro ma guarda che se non ti prendo io
guarda sei morto ci godo anzi moti porto
con me basta
smettila io mi sto siamo un po
aggrappati a caso però va bene vai io
sono aggrappato a questo completamente
in 1 bassano
ok bollaín a bola vola in alto in alto
per fargli in alto vola in alto alto
elycop no ma ragazzi non ci credo allora
prendo il barile
lo prendo lo metto aspetta che lo prendo
le mani lo metto io il barile togliti
togliti la mia non ti voglio vedere non
voglio più vederti togliti lo metto io
il barile ritirare maledizione la
vittoria come non posso giocare con la
gente così però mamma mia ma certo un
neurone in quattro lo metto io
togliti ma cosa vuoi
ma perché raiola perché sono entra ma
non ci credo ma quanta probabilità avevo
di entrare qua vuole sempre guidare lui
però non sa guidare c'è questo problema
di fondo o ti prego si ti prego si no
aspetta che si aggrappi aspetta se vuole
in alto va bene però di volare in alto
zio dio mio che che branco di beck
guarda ora dobbiamo consegnarlo alla soc
basta mi sono rotto le balle faccio
qualcos'altro con un segno io da solo le
cose faccio io no disconnect fronte
server cioè consegnare una roba in
questo gioco veramente un casinò a
l'omessa con we be everyone ma tua
sorella
non la voglio fare voglio fare questo
perché da solo finisco i livelli con voi
no doveva andare
delivered dell'holding doc ok lo sente
lo andò a questo ma devo di liberarlo lì
dentro mio dio che casino testa di culo
mi hai fatto perdere il pacco to sorella
non ancora li stai fermo che un casino
oddio mio che è successo bra bra ecco
bravo consegnato tutto va bene lo stesso
bravissimo bisogna fatta grazie a un
pacco lo abbiamo consegnato e adesso
aspetta che hai fatto tutto il casino
vieni qua adesso arrivo
jackie il clacson zia comandiamo a borca
marco la mancata ma non l'ho presa
scotta zia vieni qua un attimo per
favore
salì con me ad oggi sei sta rialzando il
ponte come veramente farmi fare questa
cosa ci provo vado io posso battagli ti
aiuto vabbè cos'è sta roba
occhio sono schiantate lolche di come ma
che figata
a voi anch'io entrare in questo coso
fammi entrare per favore fammi ultrà
allora mio personaggio fa la fa le cose
da solo c'è ha voluto suicidio
maledizione è difficilissimo prenderesti
affari però fermano un attimo voglio
provarlo fermalo cosa vuoi
se vuole questa maturità ma chissà ma
non statali mona mentre fate le scoregge
va via
togliti tenuto f per calciare golfo ma
basta che sta succedendo cava e morte
morta dotato il bacio della morte
ora occhio farmi provare zia un attimo
per favore fammi salire o vai puoi
partire vai io la vedo veramente grigie
raga non so voi ma la vedo abbastanza
grigia grojec in camus mi facci
divertire già viene da vomitare questo
gioco comunque doveva essere un qualcosa
di consegne che non è però vabbè oh mio
dio a aumentava la velocità bravissima
proprio quello che volevo
basta basta mi sono rotto le balle è
bello però sto gioco complimenti hanno
fatto rocket league è un gioco così da
me vai racket
questi va il turbo ecco mamma mia che
rockets bellissimo vorrei avere la palla
in tutto questo ma non so in quanti cosa
riuscirei a fare in minore ma forse
neanche uno ragazzi io concludo cioè nel
senso penso di non poter più darvi oltre
un gioco incredibile io sono molto
orgoglioso di portare queste cose belle
non è l'ora che esca spera che sia stato
di vostro gradimento il mio lasciate un
commento mi piace iscrivetevi al canale
cliccata la campanella così vede la
notifica dei nuovi video che arrivano
iscrivetevi anche al secondo canale e
noi ci vediamo come sempre ad una
prossima consegna di pacchi da ragazzi
[Musica]